okay so this is me I'm going to be
talking about building large-scale
developer communities from scratch for
my keynote session just like I have been
introduced I do a lot of communities
especially across the African continent
um I am the founder of secret Africa she
called Africa as a non-profit
organization for women in technology in
Africa I am also the co-founder of Open
Source Community Africa which is also
Community for open source enthusiasts
experts and everyone in between
just like
um mentioned earlier I'm also the
community manager for sub-Saharan Africa
at Google what this means is that I help
Google build developer build and manage
its Google developer groups programs
that's the gdg program and the women
techmaker Ambassador programs across
sub-Saharan Africa now over the course
of time I've been fortunate enough to
also you know find other
initiatives that are focused on
developer relations I'm a huge
um fan of devil and fully focus on
everything they've wrought so one of my
ways of giving back to communities to
also run something called devrel lights
helping newbies and everyone interested
in getting a career in developer
relations and every now and then I also
identify as a technical writer and a
tech content creator so like I mentioned
earlier my talk is going to be focused
on building communities and
the reason why I wanted to talk about
this is aside from all of the things
that I do across the different
communities and programs that I run
communities have you know proven to now
become a very vital part of the
developer ecosystem and more and more
communities are being brought up or
being realized or you know founded every
new day for every single day
so the focus areas of this my talk is
going to focus on fundamentals of
community goal and vision setting
Milestones Team Network Courage and
diversity and inclusion because you
cannot build a large-scale community
without putting into mind the aspect of
diversity and inclusiveness in your
community activities now the average
person would want that why is this talk
important to me why should I focus on
this talk aside from people who
primarily benefits from Community
aspects were in this instance we're
looking at developers there are also
people who benefit from community
activities as thought parties or
third-party stakeholders have people
like Founders who are running
um organizations we have people at sea
level executive level they have CTO CMOS
and Co and we also have people in other
fields that are beneficiaries of
community programs so in one way or the
other this also ties down to your role
as long as you're involved in the tech
ecosystem this also ties down to your
role
the first thing first why should
I be interested in building a developer
Community or why should my company be
interested in giving it developer
community
I have a couple of points that I put
down here the first that I have men
highlighted here is to provide a primary
Essence and support system around
products Dev tool or field products in
the sense that you could be running a
developer product and your community
program for that product will provide a
primary Essence and help people better
understand how to utilize your products
or just create a support system but then
beyond just working as customer care it
also does the same thing for devtools
and Fields a lot of times we see a lot
of communities printing up around
different views in um in Tech an example
is what I do with open source coming
into Africa in other words Oscar I was
using the word Oscar for a large part of
my talk today
a lot of yeah a lot of what I do is um
for Oscar it's focused on open source
open source is a few what we're helping
people do is we're helping people get
together within the African ecosystem as
long as you identify as someone in Tech
um an Amazon Africa in Africa in Tech
interested in open source we have
created the community around that field
another thing is it helps simplify
developer markets penetration
many of us might know that the developer
Market is quite different from the
normal or the average Market out there
meaning that it can be a little bit more
difficult while trying to
um while trying to drive usage and
Adoption of your developer to learn
products happy and developer communities
around you help simplify this Market
penetration in other words it's easier
for you to have developers embrace your
products when there's a community around
because that company is going to be
showing supports a large example is how
let's use a platform like stack Overflow
has been able to you know Provide
support with people providing answers
um having the ability to ask questions
and things like that it has created some
sort of community where you can always
go to to get responses or answers to
anything as regards to Tech
another thing is that it creates a
talent pipeline which boils down to the
first thing I said earlier as to why
this talk
um involves everyone and involves every
role it creates a talent pipeline sense
that the people who are part of those
communities are aside from the fact that
they identify as your users or their
identifiers or members they are also
they also have a career of their own in
the center some of them might be back
and Engineers they might be frontal
Engineers they might be designers my
product managers or whatever it is and
having that Community helps create that
talent pool or pipeline for your program
for your community for your organization
to create some sort of pipeline from
Community into full-time career
then the last one is building
communities help you you know help
growth in your career and sometimes it
also brings out spotlights or gives you
the opportunity to get that Spotlight
I'll use myself as a good example for
this what I do
uh with the different communities a
large chunk of everything that I do and
the reason why I'm here today is because
of the communities that I've been
involved with from day one everyone up
until my role at Google all of the
things that I've been able to do is
because of the activities that I have
put up in these different communities
that have been able to speak for me some
running communities you know also helps
in your career growth or even being a
part of it also helps in your career
growth and it gives you a spotlight
opportunity because it places you as a
thought leader within your ecosystem as
well
[Music]
so first of all I'll start with
fundamentals of community
there are a couple of things that you
need to understand okay now I have
decided to build a community around my
developer product or around a particular
field or around a particular tool what
are the things that I need to do the
first thing you need to look out for is
creating a naming or definition system
for your community
this like having a newborn baby at some
point you are going to have to name your
baby just so that you know in terms of
identity it's easy for people to
identify with that Community or in this
example with that baby or with that
person so you need to create a name and
definition for your community this kind
of sets the primary foundation for every
life in their Community is going to be
involved with it many times it's not a
theme casting Stone if you're not
foolishing sense that you want to revamp
the naming later on but the very first
thing you need to look at is you know
creating an immunode definition system
for your community and the second thing
is also to be able to create goals and
values the goal and values for me for
anybody who has worked directly with me
or who has reached out to me for advice
and community building and things like
that I like to amplify on goals and
values because that creates the
primary foundation for everything that
you're doing within your community in
the sense that your goal
creates that invisible boundary as to
this is what this community is focused
on these are the values that this
community is focus on and why do I say
this I'm going to amplify this later on
on my talk but just to address this here
why do you have to place a lot of focus
on your goals and values because in
community there's a lot of elements
being thrown around community building
is a lot of trial and error and a lot of
times the voice of your community
members directs
um the growth part of your community
meaning that many times you'll have
people who and who don't primarily
identify with what you're doing try to
suggest things people are bringing up um
suggestions people are bringing in
feedback there's so many moving elements
and sometimes you can get so confusing
and so
frustrating to the point where you're
making changes here and there and then
after a while it doesn't really identify
with the primary reason why instead of
that Community which is why your goals
and value need to be defined right from
um starts so you know that these are the
boundaries that I can
um I I can't go beyond and the things
that this community is focused on
the next thing you need to Define in the
primary audience I'm putting primary
there because when it comes to community
building you have multiple audience you
have primary you have secondary and you
have tertiary audience a primary
audience are the people that your
community activities or whatever it is
they're doing your community directly
affects in this instance
um for openers coming to Africa and what
I do at Chico Africa are community
members are our primary audience are our
direct community members I'll use Oscar
in for a better example
our primary audience are people who are
interested in open source people who are
already into open source contribution or
development and then people who are yeah
so
those two experts in it
cool they sorry for secondary audiences
are people who do not necessarily
um identify as members of the community
of participants are coming to
stakeholders and communities but are
affected by the actions of your primary
audience so you need to also be able to
Define your primary audience and the
last thing is you need to be able
to a more creative
platforms sometimes people think about
platform doesn't really affect what
happens in your community or the type of
activities that you run in your
community or in general everything about
your community but a place if you draw
there are some views there are some
tools there are some products where we
try to create communities there are
certain platforms that are much more
convenient for it because that's what is
more popular and that's what people are
primarily used to for example when it
comes to say I want to start a community
around an nft project the primary
platform that I want to use is a Discord
platform because that's much more common
and popular within the crypto space and
the NFC space as well unlike say I want
to start a community or maybe a
particular field say cloud engineer just
a random field and I decided to want to
use flag because that's more career
focused and when it comes career for
course platforms a lot of people tilt
towards slack as well so your platform
determines a lot of things and these are
the four basic things that I like to say
as fundamentals when you're trying to
build a developer community in this
instance we're going to be focusing on
building large-scale developer
communities but these are just primary
things that you need to set up whenever
you want to run a community of the
community regardless of if you want it
to be large scale or small scale
so next thing now after setting up your
fundamentals I'm really understanding
what your fundamentals of community
should be the next thing you want to do
is your goal and vision
so goals and vision basically helps me
Define your organs I mentioned this
earlier it also helps you define your
impact boundaries I talked about this a
little bit earlier impact boundaries I
use this word because
in the sense that the people that
directly affect other are directly
impacted by what you do within a
community you need to be able to set a
boundary so for example you want to run
a community of cloud engineering a cloud
engineering Creator just people who are
focused on cloud engineering and say
somebody who is focused on design
decides to join your community because
it's a Tech Community
if you're not able to Define your impact
boundary it means that you might at some
point go beyond focusing on cloud
engineering related activities
um programs initiatives I try to also
accommodate the needs of those who are
the designers or who identify as
designers and are not there because of
cloud engineering so creating the impact
boundary your goals and vision help you
define your impact but just say this
community is for cloud Engineers or
people who are into Cloud engineering
and that's everything will be focused on
that way when other people try to join
your community you're able to tell them
I'm sorry but this may not be the right
Community if it's for you
the lessons it helps you understand your
community wants and it I think that this
is quite explanatory but I would try to
do a little bit more Justice to it
Community wants and needs in the sense
that like the example I gave earlier
when somebody else tries to join a
community or someone tries to join your
program or your activity basically your
community you're able to you know
understand that this is not what you
need and this is these are things that
you know actually works for the people
who are part of your community
[Music]
and
then
so to set your goals and vision the
um questions that you need to ask I have
categorized them into a couple of more
questions so who this is when trying to
Define this of things that use they
might try to define the issue you're
looking at who are the beneficiaries so
keyword beneficiaries or people you're
going to be impacting your program who
are the primary beneficiaries of this
community so you're running a community
around
um a product maybe an API tool and you
want people to develop us to be able to
utilize this who are the primary
beneficiaries of this product that
um in this instance it will be
developers packet and developers
specifically people who are going to be
able to integrate their API into their
products
what do they do what gender what race
agency do they identify as when you're
able to Define all of this it helps you
really understand how best to cater the
needs of that Community towards the goal
of the community as well the next thing
you need to be able to Define is the
what part what am I trying to achieve do
I have a mass capacity I would give an
example of
um what she could Africa
I knew that the whole part for me
beneficiaries are basically women who
identify as Africans in Africa and
identify as women in Tech those are two
things for me what do they do as long as
they were in Tech as long as they were
in technical fields in Tech then they
are okay to be beneficiaries of those
community that support Africa what
Jennifer it was basically going to focus
on the men what race African so
primarily black
and Etc in the world's path what am I
trying to achieve what am I trying to
achieve which could Africa we're trying
to make sure that you know we're
creating that as much diversity and
bringing in as much gender inclusiveness
in the tech African Tech ecosystem do I
have a mass capacity while starting at
Chicago Africa this was not a primary
thought of mine but this is something
that over the course of time I've been
able to know this is something that
needs to be defined for anybody else
who's starting out a community so do I
have a Max Capacity in the sense that
while running a community do I want it
to be Max of maybe 1 000 people 10 000
people this is a actually very vital
question if you're really really
interested in or really really looking
to building large-scale developments and
my large skill I mean
from 1 000 members open above
the other thing that you need to be able
to Define is beware this is something
that not everyone puts into
consideration especially if your
community is a global type of community
an example is
um an example is a gdg program although
gdg program is also broken down into
different regions by gdg I mean Google
developer groups it's also popular into
different regions but yes the where
location plays an important part in how
your audience assimilates your activity
and your community what works for the
African continent might not necessarily
work for the European continent what
works for person a in XYZ region might
not work for person B in ABC region so
all of these things play a huge part and
a huge role in trying to Define and
build a developer community
and then like I mentioned earlier about
Community platform this also determines
the level of interest and participation
so for example with the example I gave
earlier on where an nft project and
e-club engineering program on slack and
this on Discord if you try to
Interchange that you might not get much
um success because those are two your
switching
um platforms that already work for each
of these sectors into the other one and
you're trying to experiment even though
yes I know that Community Building takes
in a lot of experiments but a lot of
times it might not be worth it if people
have already carried out that experiment
and you know have been able to Define
what works and what doesn't work anymore
and the last thing you need to be able
to Define is the why why am I doing this
why are we trying to build a developer
Community around R2 why am I trying to
build a developer Community for this
particular field what exactly is the
reason because just like every career in
Tech you need to be able to Define your
reason you need to be able to every now
and then draw yourself back to the
reason why you started this at the first
place for me for open source coming to
Africa the reason myself and my
co-founder outside status is because we
looked around and noticed that there
wasn't an active community of Open
Source enthusiasts developers or experts
or contributors within the African
ecosystem and sometimes that one and for
Chico Africa the reason why I said start
that was because I wasn't seeing as much
diversity as I was surrounded with at
the bigger places so I needed to create
a community and a platform that would be
able to build these girls up to the
point where there are Global places and
spaces where they're able to Showcase
their talents so you need to be able to
have a reason behind your motive for
companies running developer communities
around the products your business could
be or you know you're trying to get more
users you're trying to open more users
you're trying to get more uh more number
of Integrations on your products and
things like that the reasons are
entirely different for different people
but you need to be able to have a reason
why I've seen communities companies also
make a mistake on this where they just
started developer Community for the sake
of starting it because it's something
that they see as now rampant and then
after two months three months that
Community died because there's no
sustainability structure around it
then all the question is can I make it
sustainable this is also a very vital
question when people talk about talk
about sustainability they think about or
funding are we able to sustain this with
money but it goes beyond just funding it
goes um you're also looking at things
around the people running that Community
you're looking at the interest from the
community you're looking at the users or
the members of that Community as well is
this something that's sustainable say
for example you're very specific about
the niche the gender the race and
um different metrics you're very
specific about them do you think that
this is sustainable for the next two to
three years because for large-scale
developer communities you don't plan for
two months three months what you plan
for is
um year-long plans for sustainability so
you need to think about all of these
things Beyond funding even though
funding is like 50 to 40 percent uh when
it comes to priority list it's a top
priority because you need to have money
to be able to run a lot of the
activities that you run for like I said
sustainability goes beyond just funding
so you need to be able to ask yourself
is it possible to make this sustainable
what do I need to be able to make this
sustainable
and the next thing you need to look at
is mouth bones this is something that we
were able to Define while starting at um
Oscar and Chico Africa
so basically what I'm asking milestones
and metrics that help you determine the
growth curve of your community
in the sense that
um there are different items that help
your pointers and help you stay okay I
have gotten to this level that I I think
that we have we are at sea level when it
comes to a community building we have
achieved this certain criteria certain
landmark and things like that so for us
at Chico Africa the first Milestone we
had was being able to train 1 000 women
because it has it ties down with our
goal at what we're trying to do in
Chicago Africa your Milestone could be
being able to onboard your first user
your Milestone could be
um having at least 10 to 15 members of
your community be able to say that they
have moved from point A to point B as
regards their growth curve that's
awkward movement your Milestone could be
saying that
um XYZ have been able to get this one so
working opportunities from your talent
pipeline Milestones are entirely
different and unique to different
communities but basically there are
metrics that would help you determine
the growth of your community in the
sense that your growth curve could be
upward it could be downwards I mean it
could be positive it could be negative
it could be either going backwards or
forward but these are mentioned I would
really help you and a lot of times for
me an advice until I like to give is
when setting these metrics don't set
metrics that are easily achievable and
while you're doing that also do it in a
year-long plan sometimes it will be in
short term it could be short-term
metrics it'd be long-term metrics
however it's entirely up to you
an example of Milestones that people
like to use and I personally outside to
use this numbers say for example trained
1000 women
um
had 1 000 um participants participates
in Octoberfest program
Etc data is a huge thing when it comes
to community and when it comes to
Milestone setting another thing it could
be your success stories in a sense that
how are you able to tell success stories
of your members has anybody
have you gotten any success story from
your community since you started was
that success story your success story
could be like okay for my Milestone my
first success story that I want as a
milestone would be when we get when
somebody gets a new job from our
community it's entirely up to you the
other would be um product or platform
integration just like I mentioned
earlier it could be still it could still
be related to numbers it may not be
related to numbers
the other one is conversion in the sense
that how many people were you able to
take from point A to point B
this can be how many people was able to
take from either a community event by
speaking to them and onboarding them
into being members of our community or
users of our community
how many people moved from being Junior
developers to being senior developers
just in this community conversion also
kind of tallies down with success
stories but there's a thin fine line
difference between both of them as well
so conversion can be in Talent it can be
awareness awareness in the sense that
how many people have moved from being
members of the community to being
Advocates of your community in sense
that word of mouth Advocate you're not
spending so much on social media
publicity and all of those things about
your community but people are able to
advocate for you this is a milestone for
me that we um prioritize but that SCA
that she could Africa and open source
community in Africa
so there's so many maps and examples but
these are just some that I like to use
and a lot of communities that I have
worked with as well like to use
so next thing now is team I think that
this is quite self-explanation when
you're running a community
um you can't do it alone because it it
beats the idea of what community means
you need a team of people and a healthy
Community one thing people don't know
that is that a healthy Community when
you see a healthy or Tribune community
means that there are a lot of people or
a number of people who are putting extra
effort Behind these things just to keep
that running
community building is harder to thrive
as a Lone Ranger you need individuals
who are committed to the goals and
vision of that Community this is very
very primary because Community Building
searching for last year of developer
communities it's a long-term thing and
if you don't have people who are
primarily committed to the goal and
addition of that Community it's easy for
them to Fall by the way um roadside or
along the way they could tell your
priorities have changed if you don't
have people who genuinely believe in
what you're trying to do with that
Community it's very difficult to have
them build for a long time
you also need to have people who
understand the essence of teamwork now
one thing that I want to say on this is
okay so what I want to say on this is
while you know trying to start or create
a team for your community it doesn't
have to be
um a paid role if you can afford a Pedro
that's fine if you can't afford a period
there are lots of people out there who
are still committed to building in
long-term communities just based on
being volunteers for she called Africa
and open source coming to Africa we've
been able to create very actively
functional things of food I won't really
call them full-time protesters but I'll
volunteers every one of the team are all
volunteers I also identify as a
volunteer for both secret Africa and
business Community Africa but I've been
able to run each of them because she
called Africa has been running for six
years with the same thing for open
source Community Africa is running for
about three four years with the same
team as well because these are people
who are committed to the goal and vision
of what we're doing they also see it as
their own
um child project or their baby child
product as well and they also understand
the essence of Teamwork because you
can't access really lead a team or you
can't necessarily work in a team where
nobody against um understands the
essence of teamwork everyone wants to
identify as an individual and you can
have
um different people leading different
roles and failing to communicate
communication is a huge thing when it
comes to building communities and then
lastly you need to be able to consider
that they need to be willing to take
ownership of their roles as much as yes
they're all volunteers when it comes to
building large-scale developer
communities a lot of elements um like I
mentioned earlier there are lots of
moving elements and you need to have
people who are able to take ownership of
their roles stay in charge of things but
also understand the idea of teamwork
then for Network or reaches also another
thing that you need to be able to
consider to reach a large network of
people in your program
it is very very vital to either evaluate
or re-evaluate this remember this talk
was beyond just Building Development
communities but building large-scale
developer communities in Africa you're
very unfortunate enough to have
communities
um that have said from scratch and grown
into some of the largest communities I
myself personally aside from what I do
at Google at secret Africa at open
source Community Africa I have been very
fortunate enough to be at the Forefront
of leading a lot of these large
developer communities and it was still
Wednesday from zero members into now
having over five thousand twenty five
thousand thirty thousand members for
these different communities
so to reach a large network of people on
your program you need to be able to
evaluate or re-evaluate these things
what's the number of people we want to
get across to do you have a cabbage
buzzer to what I explained earlier is
there maximum capacity to the number of
community members you need in a
community this is something you need to
really really consider because that
would also now help you figure out when
it comes to the events and activities
that you need to hold within your
community as well or initiatives
when you figure out the number how do
you intend to reach them now these
things that I'm highlighting in Black
are things that I want you to focus on
number of people how do we plan to reach
them how do you plan to engage them do
you have self-events or do you want to
reach your community based off of
sponsoring other events do you have a
particular format for reaching your
community or reaching the people of the
number of people you want to get in
coming so for example you want to have a
community of 10 000 people how do you
plan to get that 10 000 number do you
want to do it just by you know
a standalone Community doing your thing
do you want to integrate with other
communities maybe from their events
activities sometimes I see a lot of
companies trying to build developed
communities focus more on sponsorships
sponsorship but there's really no
structure around the actual Community
because sponsorships and events only
help you provide a platform to gather
people together but what happens after
that event do you have a follow-up
platform um follow-up format do you have
an onboarding
um onboarding format to get to convert
these people from being attendees into
being community members these are things
that you need to consider under your
reach how do you plan to reach these
community members and that goal of the
number of people that you want are you
deliberate about Grassroots options
that's on the served locations another
mistake that a lot of people and
companies make one chance to build our
developer communities is that they focus
on the central areas San Francisco Lagos
Nairobi South Africa Johannesburg in
South Africa Etc this Center sharp
places and just because the attendees on
there but a lot of time tends to have a
little bit of Internet a lot of time
you'll notice that your members are
people who are Beyond this location so
how are you
um being deliberate about reaching
people in this Grassroots locations
because numbers number regardless of
whatever location it is they're coming
from accept your program or your
communities directly focused on
um having their primary audience as
people from a specific location if
you're trying to build Global
communities that people were doing they
need to be very very deliberate about
Grassroots um Grassroots options how are
you reaching these people in on the Sub
locations as well then the last thing is
how do you continuously amplify an
awareness
um while building communities it's a
hundred percent non-stop awareness you
have to keep talking about Community you
have to keep amplifying about what your
community is about because a community
is almost like a tunnel people keep
going in and coming out it's non-stop
meaning that you can't get a particular
point and say you know what we are done
we amplifying what we're doing about
Community we have the popularity we have
the platform we're just going to relax
there's there's no relaxing when it
comes to building large-scale developer
communities unfortunately so you need to
be very conscious about constantly
amplifying on awareness
while you're doing 50 of the work now
I'm very specific about this 50 of the
work why did I put 50 of the work you
want to get your community to a point
where people are doing more of the work
for you by advocating for you
an example to start overflow developer
Community I don't know
um much about
um what it takes to run the community
internally but if you're a developer
regardless of what country what
continent you're in you definitely know
about stack Overflow community
it has gone to this point where
day nights the people constantly talking
about that Community you want to get
your community to that point where you
don't have to run ads excess is very
very vital you don't have to do so much
work one tweet could go longer because
there's so many people who are
constantly talking about what you're
doing with that sweet it's different
when you are much more focused on
running I've done people doing the world
of my advocacy for you so how do you
continuously amplify an awareness do you
have local chapters does your program
allow your afford to the opportunity to
have local chapters who probably
implement what you're doing on a global
scale in a much more smaller scale that
leads to awareness as well do you have
an ambassador or advocacy program
basically what you should be looking at
is how am I able to get people to start
talking on behalf of my community
speaking only have my community for us
Beyond where we are for chicken Africa
and Oscar one thing that we have
prioritized for this is that we have
started local chapters because we know
that we're not able to reach
as many people as we want to as good of
our community would want to just by
doing what we do at a global scale so we
have set up local chapters in specific
locations that we know that there's an
interest of Open Source interlocation
but distance is an issue
and it's the same thing with Ambassador
advocacy programs does your
um your community run Ambassador
programs do you have brand ambassadors
who are talking technical brand
ambassadors do you have
um Advocates it goes beyond just
developer Advocates do you have
Community Advocates who are speaking on
Behavior they could all be volunteers as
well maybe telling them like a token or
something or it's different but these
are all volunteers who are not under
your pay who have been able to you know
amplify on what you're doing with your
community
then diversity and inclusion you really
cannot want to build a large-scale
developer community and not think of
diversity because there's no way that's
not going to create an issue later on in
the sense that if you've been in Alaska
to government you have to be very
conscious about gender diversity race
diversity language diversity because
you're going to having people from most
likely all across the globe or if it's
focused on the continent from all across
that continent if you're intentional
about it so diversity is something that
you really need to consider because it
helps your Innovation and growth when
there's diversity at the table there's
diversity and thoughts there's diversity
in actions you know getting feedback
from numerous people and it's yielding
Innovation not all feedback yes um would
be accepted but it helps you see things
from a different perspective and it
helps you feel the pain as well from a
different perspective it also provides
you know inclusive actions and decisions
because you're putting you're coming
together as one you're being very very
in implementing the feedback that
specific sort of people tell you as well
then it's just it four stars is
sustainable and open Community I think
that's self-explanatory and then at the
heart of it all there's a certain joy
and pride that rests on your face
knowing that your community played a
vital role in someone's growth that's
literally for me the primary Essence and
beauty of developer communities knowing
that out there one person has benefited
from what you're doing with your
community could be in terms of talents
or hiring or job change or career change
it could be in sense that maybe your
soul has helped
um
someone saw a particular issue that they
have been focused on for a very long
time at the end of the day is knowing
that at least one person out there is
benefiting from the efforts they're
putting into your community
so thank you all very much I have come
to the end of my
um talk I'm open to questions if there
are any but you can also reach out to me
on any other social platforms at color
codex or you can reach out to me on
LinkedIn
thank you
thank you Ada uh so
um let's wait
um a couple moments to see if anybody
has questions in the chat
um in the meantime I would like to ask
you a question uh about building
communities uh so it's like you've been
building communities across Africa like
uh have you had to deal with uh sort of
not just in person like talking with
each other but also you know I'm sure
there's also a lot of online uh Zoom
Community online communication as well
right so I was just wondering do you
have any like tips for that because I
think sometimes it's very hard to engage
um when it's uh virtual and you know in
fact like uh you know our PI data Global
conference is is definitely one of the
things where like we tried very very
hard to make it you know
um a bit more engaging right thanks
okay so the first thing I would say is
when it comes to Virtual communities
well all communities are going to have
virtual platforms except when it's
something like in-person meetings or
things like that you need to be very
specific if a lot of activities are
going to be happening on
um or virtually rather you need to be
very specific about the platform which
is one of the things that I talked about
earlier if you know that within that
region say for example
um you have registered implementing your
platform as slack and you know that
within that region maybe there's a much
more popular platform that people are
very more focused on I'll use Africa as
an example in Africa
um for
texts and social media platforms it's
WhatsApp that is a lot more common here
so it's very common to see WhatsApp
groups for smaller smaller
Communications so in this instance when
you notice that there's a drop in
participation or activity you can try to
move depending on the number of
community members that you have I know
that WhatsApp has a limit but you can
try to move those communities to the
smaller platforms another thing is for
virtual communities virtual activities
you need to be very very clear on the on
not you know
um feeding them with too many activities
because that can get very warming and
you have that um
um virtual events fatigue so you want to
limit the number of engaging activities
that they have online to maybe
activities that would give them time to
respond at their own convenience or
maybe do other activities that don't
involve
um one-on-one meetings or video calls or
call meetings and things like that those
are things that
um I know that has worked and I continue
to work for someone who's coming to the
platforms that are built for
uh I can ask you a question on the
comment section do I go ahead with it
yes please
okay so there's a question any
suggestions for engaging and retaining
volunteers
um for engaging and retaining volunteers
one thing I would say is you need to
just the same way you're I'm
continuously advocating about your
community externally for your volunteers
you need to be able to
um re-emphasize about why you're doing
that um why you're building your
community what you're doing your
community you need to be because for
volunteers as long as there's no pay at
some point every now and then the moral
is definitely going to be low and you
need to be able to
um they need to feed up your energy
either as a community lead or as a team
lead or as a Founder if you're a founder
of a community so doing that you need to
have a size team bonding activities you
also need to have sessions or activities
where if it's possible for them to meet
in person you don't have to spend a lot
of money for that it could just be
Hangouts another thing is you could have
um sessions that's focused on their own
career growth because at the end of day
what happens is if you're not focused on
your own growth what these volunteers
would see is that they're putting in
time and efforts to
yeah putting time and efforts to help
other people but they are not benefiting
from that Community as well so you need
to be more intentional about making sure
that they are also benefited from that
Community because they are volunteering
their time so you could have expert
sessions where you just for all the
volunteers bring in an expert to come
talk to them at a particular field
another thing is if you can you know
provide stipends provide swag packs
provide discounts whatever it is that
you can
um and in some we just think of other
ways that if you were a volunteer how
would you want to benefit from that
program that you're volunteering from
Beyond you know just having people
successfully to keep inspiring to have
the answers that question
thank you
okay so I think I I will be leaving the
stage now thank you so much everyone
please remember you can reach out to me
if you have questions commentaries
whatsoever it says
um
okay I see that they're still they're
still
um a question okay one more question
you talked about tracking metrics could
you share some metrics or success cases
for scn Oscar okay
um I would
okay so for SCA which is secret Africa I
would share an example and then I'll
share one for Oscar for SCA a vision
metric that we have been working towards
for
um a while in miles per month so that we
have mortgage towards is you know we've
been running the community for
approximately yeah for over six years
now six years in a couple of months and
we have grown to 18 000 African women in
the continent and for us another
Milestone
um a couple of Milestones first
Milestone was you know when you're
training 1 000 women second milestone
was crossing 5 000 community members
told Milestone ten thousand and all and
then now that we have you know crossed
that 10th came out 2015 came out so now
we are 18K because committee is going
rapidly and we have just you know come
out from kovid and usually organizing
in-person events a milestone that we
said to ourselves this year was having a
gathering for all of our community
members just so that this Milestone was
also going to focus on a couple of other
things around one
um helping us as a court team we
understand that we assess the impact of
all of the work that we have been doing
for a very long time because there's
clearly a difference when you have an
in-person events when you have a virtual
event because you're able to see your
community members in real time you're
able to see with your own eyes the level
of of impact when you see how many
people have gathered so that was a
milestone for us that we recently just
crossed last month November by the way
happy new month everyone if you're
already in December yeah so that was a
milestone for us
um on the Oscar part of
um things
the first major metric and that we had
to work towards to achieve a milestone
was also towards um having a first ever
largest open source Gathering so for us
it was a goal and it was also a metric
in the sense that the goal was to have
the largest African Gathering or
Conference of African open source
developers contributions literally
everyone in open source because we had
never seen anything like that in all of
Africa
and that was also a metric for us so it
was a gold slash metric or master
so I hope that answers that question but
like I said
um metrics and metrics for a milestone
is entirely unique to different
communities it can be numbers can be
success stories whatsoever it is some
success cases that we've had for SCA
even recently just day before yesterday
one of our community members moved
located to Canada she started her
journey from Chicago Africa she was a
medical student and now she's a computer
science undergraduate at University of
Carlton I'm correct and she's also
working at Shopify so that is a success
story from for us because she was able
to kick off her Tech Career and get a
very solid background in high tech
Journey before moving to this other
place so these are all different success
stories metrics that
um people tried people tend to look out
for either when they're building their
communities or when they're trying to
join the community because that also
helps tell them if this community is
great or not
thank you